bello di ragazzi benvenuti di questo
video o lordi non so perché non si sono
degnati mango di mettere il nome è un
gioco di marionette ho letto cioè lo
stesso non ho capito bene un cacchio di
però buon giorno perfetto ecco qua
limited edition collectibles cioè sono
bambole delimitata veramente orribili
tra l'altro credo coro madonna che corsa
ciao a tutti pazzesco a posso
nascondervi dentro l'eco bellissima
veramente figo però non ho capito da chi
mi devo nascondere esattamente spiegami
collezione le batterie e
accendi gli oggetti per aiutarti nel
midex sono già accesi questo non devo
accedeva a scendere altre cose haven le
slot hanno allora è devo ficcare le
batterie qua dentro praticamente bello è
una l'abbia messa e questa non serve a
niente però ce n'è un'altra che non
serve una sega mi mancano le batterie va
bene e dove lettore dove trovo in giro
vediamo
a chase batterico ma posso [ __ ] le
batterie dall'altra parte bellissimo ok
perfetto hanno tolta un'altra cosa cia
dibatte la sveglia ma sto male nella
server io posso posso attivare le cose e
disattivare gola bene questa
interessante devi anche metterla nel
verso giusto e la cosa che mi fa cioè mi
fa morì sta roba è assurdo in un gioco
xi di ficcare le batterie è sempre stata
la mia o incubo questo che non sale
venuto le l'udeur una lattina va bene
c'è gente
bellissimo va bè ragazzi allora
passandola
lei se devo trovare delle card audience
card devo trovare 6 va bene nel mentre
c'è qualcuno che mi sento porca [ __ ]
ma kick ass
ma è orribile
era noi che sedia francese va bene ma
allora ma che brutto ragazzi la persona
più brutta che abbia mai visto va bene
ok
devo evitare che il francese vi figli e
chi si voleva pia dalla francia nessuno
quelli a posto va bene tutto questo devo
cercare di scappare da quello
chiuso la palla ce l'ha fatta non ci
credo solo talento perché non corre più
non corre più ora col allora corro entra
di qua ma possibile che sono entrato
nell'unico posto nel mondo dove c'era
quel tizio mi metto qualche foto qua
sotto
mi sa che mi piglia non ho la
presunzione
è passato sulla trappola eccolo a prosto
ce l'ho fatta non so come va bene
vi devo stare attento che tizio nomi
pighi va bene e activate trap
innanzitutto quindi io devo devo trovare
batterie in giro e trovare così le carte
va bene è un gioco stranissimo comunque
sullo scrivere non mai giocata una roba
del genere però va bene dove trovo
esattamente le batterie stavolta
grammofono pieno pieno piano piano piano
ti dà tutte tutte tutte le presunte
fantastico
fantastico ci siamo e vale allora e
adesso che un po aperto sta roba
expo nello neighbor un po di strano però
il tizio dall'altra parte devo muovere
il culetto sono caz
la messa in pratica
porca [ __ ]
lo pensavo ci mettessero si può che
arrivare piccola che palle e
difficilissimo madonna mia dove l'hai
spacebar riproviamoci rai è un casino ma
questa è roba qua si possono usare noi
cosa siamo solo per togliere la batteria
e va bene quando trovate due ottimo ne
ho cinque guardano più di prima che
appena partorita per di più dopo dentro
giudico dentro di sé chiusi
e lo sta facendo
ma cosa ma dove no ragazzi non ho
veramente non ho parole cosa ho visto
ero lì cos'è cosa ho fatto non ho capito
se devo stare attento al tipo che mi
seguiva il burattino cioè di stronzo
burattino
captare
ho chiuso la porta
madonna incredibile incredibile
proprio lui
non può sapere che sono qua dentro
ragazzi stavi facendo dimostra roba ma
non subito perché ma va bene non può
sapere che sono qua dentro ragazzi è
impossibile
è bellissimo perché fa anche le rime
cioè la roma che non ha senso attenzione
agli atti mentre ok unisex facevo dentro
il cesso
va bene ho trovato uno stomaco di stoffa
ottimo
che cazzo riga ora c'è la carta questa è
la carta va bene
piccola batteria e come poi
a devo completare il giochino dove deve
riconoscere i versi me ottimo d'aria che
la papera
l'asinello
matex di gioco era e ma cos'è era ho
trovato andrà trovata un po trovato la
prima ce n'è una sola beh ottimo ho
trovato una sola carta me ne mancano
altre 27 ma va bene un'altra carta
un'altra posso prendere la lampada quale
a distanza anno di attività ed ok così
via spiga la
alla guerra questo dovrà questo va bene
lo trovate due ragazze mai giocare un pò
us linderman un po a venerdì 13 ho
potuto ai ragazzi prova bene ok seconda
carta let's go mamma mia che player
ragazzi che player devo andare a trovare
altre batterie in giro ragazzi perché a
verona c'è un'altra perfetto e non
trovate tre attenzione sempre questa
prefetto
e siamo a tre dove è andato il maledetto
inchiostro non lo so lo devo cercare in
giro va intanto cerchiamo lo c'è
un'altra carta c'è un trattato che aveva
prima questo comunque ragazzi non si sta
capendo una sega non so cosa mi serva
l'inchiostro noi l'idea in un minuto
parte la performance nonché di interessi
chissà quanto ma di che parliamo che
capitan ha
tratto lo zio dove cacchio è che da un
ora che non lo vedo meno male tra
l'altro non lo vedo la performance
iniziato a 40 secondi
performance de che a doverlo dove
la [ __ ]
io chiudo la porta si sa mai e vorrei
assistere alla che fa
vorrei assistere a performance ma non so
dove dove devo andare una idea di tanto
smesso
ma dov'è dove era eccolo che performance
dovrebbe essere questa spiega mi va bene
e ragazzi oltre carte
o merda merda merda corre
veloce scritta
madonna lega si sono riattivate tutte le
trappole tra l'altro lo so come ma va
bene
così
ok no come ragazzi ma il palco a tono
mamma ma non mi ha preso mai el altra
stanza totalmente ma dove va bene
ragazzi questa era come che si chiama
sto gioco ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto cose il suo è un mi piace anche
vari social descrizione r sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video ei ragazzi
[Musica]